what are you doing here let me in alex
because she is mitch's equal she is a
white woman of privilege
she has experienced a certain kind of
mitch
and so
she's really trying to wrestle with
her experience of mitch and who she
knows him to be with other women's
experiences of him i want to be better i
want to be a better person
please no seriously alex
i just i want to be a good person as
human beings we are fallible we are
capable of horrible things we are
capable of wonderful things and we
don't make enough room in this moment
for contrition
to be able to say sorry to mean it to
move on we're dealing with it in the
best way we can on the show because i
think it's really important because that
is the big question is there redemption
for anyone and he's trying to understand
he really wants to do better it's just
time for me to go we were quarantined i
know that you don't actually want to
leave so could we just stop with the
pretending valeria golino oh she's so
incredible she's one of the most free
wonderful actors i've ever worked with
she's just
not afraid of anything and her character
represents someone who has no judgment
on mitch yes he has a past but she
accepts him for who he is valeria
understood it all immediately you know
and there's an irreverence
to her
and they're kind of daring to her as a
performer that paula needed and we saw
it right away
okay you're going to come here
i'm on a mission
our writers always knew that mitch would
pass away this season one of the things
that we talked about is how when someone
passes the story about them can shift
and it was very interesting and rich
territory to explore how people would
feel not just about mitch when he was
living but how they would feel about him
when he passed we ask
who we are as people when we've done
horrible things
are we still a human being or are we a
monster that's not for us to answer
for the audience to answer
you